hi again um
sheer naggy now i have the space
to talk about this a little more
i was showing trying to show you the
timing with the ken of how
the hands turn
you know if you watch this is in
the middle of me
it's in the middle of my body
i had a uh a friend
talking to me and i could help a friend
talking to me in the week
and we can always learn something all
teachers will say that
if they have any worth in my opinion
he answered a question that i've been
trying to sort of come to understand for
many many
years oh sensei would say
that he couldn't tell
his students because the gods wouldn't
allow him
psycho scentsy toe sensei all of the
the teachers nishio chiba
tamura all did very different and all
such wonderful people i think such
wonderful masters
i just still love watching them nearly
done 50 years so i could do and i still
admire them and
put them at so much of a higher plateau
than the ground i'm standing on
anyhow
the gods won't allow me
they couldn't understand him he he
seemed to talk in
riddles or different things now
i'm standing here talking to you and if
i say to you
i turn my hand over i turn my hand over
if i say as i turn
my hand over i'm experiencing something
i cannot explain
i could say to you the gods won't allow
me
it's because i'm experiencing it
how do you on
a lot of things in the world you can
explain to people
you know those who those who ride horses
you can say
you know that feeling you get when
you're in the saddle and the horse
starts to gallop
and they'll say oh yes i know exactly
what you mean
but i could only refined
and so personal that when we see all
these different styles of aikido
and i'm thinking oh what a lot of
rubbish why do they even bother
look how terrible it is i'm very
critical
i try to be a good person but i can't
help
seeing something and saying what are
they doing
they're gonna give i could have a bad
name and yet they think they're so good
but they're enjoying it they're they're
inside it's a as if they're in a time
warp
what their what and myself you might
think what's he on about
he uh he doesn't look that good to me
you know um i get thumbs down as well as
i get thumbs up on
on my films does it hurt my ego yes a
little bit
and then i think to myself well
what don't they like and i start trying
to
rather than build my own wallet
and say how good i am i start thinking
what are they seeing that i'm not doing
right
so i might start being judgmental within
within myself and that's a good place to
start
it's a it's a humbling so that when you
you know when you can overcome oh dear i
wonder how many thumbs down i'm going to
get from making this film
it's all a part of learning and the more
that we can accept it
and truly accept it the better our
aikido becomes
i've noticed over the years and years
of doing aikido when i got stuck
it was because i'd gone as far as i
could
technically i then had to look at
me as a person
and i then advanced because i wasn't so
judgmental
when we do ichiyo
and you come up to the person's
arm and then when you take it down
or you go to take it down and you find
this block
i found that it wasn't that i'd got the
technique wrong
or i wasn't in the wrong position i
tried
entering differently
entering differently you know moving my
body in different positions
then all of a sudden eko's became no
problem
it didn't matter who i was up against
strong small
weep tall iccio started to work
and yet it's a terrible technique i
think for
being you know i sense he said this is
the
first technique you should do so what i
tried doing and i'm
offering you to think about this when
you get
chance if you're on your own like i am
now
and you you do
the technique of course it works you
have nobody there to resist
but the want this word the want in your
mind
of wanting to achieve it wanting to do
it
wanting for it to succeed the want
is the word that is the worst part
and because you want to do it it
actually means that you are the attacker
because you want to do it so what i
tried with a few students
and they set out was but how did that
work that worked so well
i could now do it yeah
so they're here and just as they bring
their arm up
to clash and grab the elbow or
some style is open-handed throw the
thought
to the back of your head and throw it
away so this
remove the wand and just do the action
just do the action notice my feet
i come in
it turns it turns
shifts the weight it makes the other
foot come through
into their body naturally
do techniques slowly do them on your own
and if you're in lockdown we can't train
enter
you can break it down you can try
different footwork
you can try coming in opening
and doing it in one bringing it through
you can do any stages you can come one
but throw it to the back of your mind
because this is the piece you don't
realize you're doing
the want is the piece when you're with
another person
come in open the front foot like with
the ken
turning turning the foot
turning the foot bring it through
into their body
okay right from back here
and
bring the body through you hit them in
the ribs
go through
try to remember though when you do get
back to a partner
remove the want if you can remove the
one in all the techniques
and you're at a certain level then
they'll start getting better
okay so that's the ego that's the first
principle
the other thing they say is since as
soon as you
walked away i couldn't do it anymore
when you were here
i could do it it's as if
while they're in my aura they've got my
energy they've got my understanding
this i cannot explain um
is it the confidence could be you may
have the answer for this
but it's all improved
by doing the weapons
shell nagi as on the last film
you step offline
keeping the hand in front of you keeping
as you lift and you pass through
when you on the balls of your feet you
turn
and you throw down
foot and hands keep it
keep watching your hands watch your
hands what
if you can see your hands through your
eye with your eyes looking up
you can see your hands
then you follow them down your arms
should only follow them down
there's so many people who
i see doing sheer naggy
like this and it's come around the back
of their head
to the side and then they pull them down
with their arms
this is as bad as
doing the weapons like this in my
opinion
okay so rather than knock kashima
bakken that's an art in itself and it's
a very powerful art and it's nice to
watch people doing it
but those senses ken and joe were not
weapons fighting it was to improve your
titus and to improve tai jitsu
is about movement movement
movement movement
okay movement
i'll explain a little more the sheer
naggy let's do it from an angle
i turn my foot open i turn the wrists
like as i lift up i watch the hat
i watch the hands i watch the hands i
watch their hands
they must keep in front all the time so
that when you come to the other side
they're still in front
you change the shape of your body now
this position here
you can see my my posture it does look
like a bent back leg and it is a bent
leg leg and up front here
and i power
the bet the bow sends the person down
and as they're falling the arms just
follow them down
that's what that's all the arms should
do is be holding their wrist
and follow them down there should be no
you know striking action
from the arms shoulders at all
let me try another angle
here the hat you'll notice that the
hands are keeping in front of my head
all the time
to do this correctly you need to train
with somebody
some similar height if you're training
with somebody smaller
you would never do a sheer nagging in
the street it would be ridiculous the
balance is wrong
you'd do another technique somebody
much taller that's also difficult i've
talked to several teachers about this
it's not a practical technique but it's
one we have to do
and it's a very nice technique if you
have a good uk
you can get some spectacular buchemis
let's do another
curling raising up this is what happens
because the person now is heavy
or they're grounded it pulls your arms
to the back of their head when
when done incorrect and that's what
makes it so it's here
and then the pull
it comes like this and then the pull
this is wrong this is wrong
incorrect i should say
yes they won't want the pain in their
wrists
they will follow you they will follow
you like this
if you get some the same similar height
you'll find it works so those who have
got my book
it's detailed there what to do but you
should uh keep always being if you can
always see your hands in front of you
if you don't know about the feet now if
you can always see these hands in front
of you
then the technique
is correct i've opened my hands but
you know you of course should have been
gripped
around nervous i hope you find this of
some interest and not too boring
uh please subscribe if you haven't done
so already and i look forward to seeing
you soon
thank you for your time